week three power rankings time to take a
look at how the deck has been reshuffled
after the second game of the season the
top four teams
unchanged locked in even though the
patriots lost chris sims they barely
lost to the seahawks i'm letting them
hold their spot thought about putting
the bills ahead of them the bills get a
bump from seven to five the packers up
three to six titans up one to seven it's
the saints who fell three after losing
to the raiders down to number eight
that's the top ten the steelers crash
into it as well i dropped the 49ers out
of the top ten even though they won
31-13 that's one of the biggest fallers
of the week from six all the way to 13.
and it's justified even though they
destroyed the jets the injuries are too
much the nick bosa injury the killer but
all the others combined this is a
one-on-one team that right now is closer
to the middle of the pack than the top
and they're gonna have to prove that
they can win football games without
these key players chris maybe they can
yeah but they're gonna have to show it
first yeah i understand you questioning
them i do i get that i mean where we're
sitting right now yes if you're gonna
just go you go yeah they're a beat up
football team this is not the team that
i power ranked a few weeks ago that was
healthy and you know so i understand
that totally did you think at all about
moving the chiefs
because off the number one mantle
because i just would say i would have
and again i get it i'm just saying i
probably would have put the ravens at
number one just to the way they've
looked through two weeks the chiefs
being a little shaky last week and
everything there but i know it's the
kings of the hill still and nobody's
knocked them off the pedestal that's
basically your reasoning
we're going to focus more on all the two
and oh teams next hour there are 11 of
them tying a record high who are the
contenders who are the pretenders i
think we'd both agree that chiefs and
ravens are contenders but answer your
question
i i do go with the king of the hill
mentality okay easy i don't have to
rethink it it's yeah you you are as the
defending champion entitled the top spot
until someone beats you okay and you
know what the ravens get their chance on
monday night anyone out there that
doesn't like the fact that the ravens
aren't number one the ravens get their
chance to claim the top spot on monday
night and that's one of the reasons why
i left them there you know i may have
deviated from it chris if that wasn't
the next game on the schedule okay but
they get a chance to prove it on the
field monday night if the ravens are
better the ravens win if the chiefs are
better the chiefs win the game's in
baltimore so the ravens have a little
bit of an edge not the same that they'd
have if fans were actually filling up
the place we talked about the 49ers
let's revisit it when do you reach the
point of no return how many more can
they withstand before it all just falls
apart or or is your guy kyle shanahan
wired to never let it fall well he's
he's wired to never make an excuse or or
like blink at eye he'll continue to just
go like okay i got an issue here how am
i going to fix that and then let me
build a game plan around it
that's where kyle is great that way you
know can the roster handle it things
like that i mean hey we're gonna see uh
i'm i'm of course concerned as a friend
and a guy that roots for the 49ers and
things like that but i'm not concerned
to where i'm like oh the season's over
yet not no not like that because um
let's let's see let's see as we go
forward and evaluate there is still a
lot of talent on the football team
shanahan is special we're gonna get
george kittle back right there so you're
gonna have him back and debo samuel back
there will be a few guys that get mixed
back in to the healthy group here that i
think could make us change our thought
on them maybe in the next two to three
weeks to where we start to go okay yeah
i know there's no nick bosa but okay
there's d ford oh george kittle's there
debo samuel's there oh richard sherman's
back okay it's not as bad as we thought
or you know they seem to be regaining
their form they just got to kind of
weather this storm right here and see if
they can battle through it and
fortunately for them
they're playing what i would you know
yeah the giants are certainly one of the
worst teams in the game right now so uh
uh it's an evaluation i'm not panicked
but i'm a little concerned i guess
that's what i'm saying
and let's make sure we're clear on this
49ers fan close friends with kyle
shanahan they're playing your new year i
know it's messed up that your dad took
to the top of the mountain right this is
it who who are you rooting for this
weekend this is your last chance to
change your answer from last week no
it's it's kyle shanahan the 49ers i'm
sorry big blue and the giants i'm sorry
but yeah this is uh this is a a friend a
family friend uh you know i'm close to
him and as much as i love the new york
giants yes i'm gonna root for him and it
pains me trust me there is no team i
hated more growing up than the san
francisco 49ers that's why is that is
that i is that irony is that is that
classified as irony i don't i've given
up trying to figure it out because
there's no good for whatever incremental
is it 10 000 spoons and all you need a
knife i mean that's exactly right i've
given it up it's a coincidence it's
always coincidence it may not be irony
but it's always coincidence all right uh
new england patriots they're they're
justifying my faith in them pre-season
based on how they've performed
what have they done so far through two
games that you didn't expect to see
chris uh well i think the big one was
just what we saw last week the throwing
and the throwing the football had to be
the thing we had to see to go okay we
know they're gonna have creative ways to
run the ball and use cam newton and do
that type of stuff but what about that
game when a team takes away all that are
they going to be able to rely on the
drop back pass game and i think that was
the thing that surprised me more than
anything not that i was doubting it
could be successful
didn't know it could be that successful
on week two of the nfl season
in seattle who's got a much improved
secondary and of course is one of the
better teams in football so uh and yeah
we questioned we talked about this to
start the show just the receivers
themselves were they going to establish
themselves all we were told last year
was there's no weapons in new england
there's no weapons there's no weapons
and i also think hey these guys are a
year older damir byrd added to the list
and i do think this emphasizes the fact
a little bit that cam newton's willing
to stand in the pocket and throw the
ball down the field these are the things
that were the issues with brady last
year that no one wanted to blame brady
everybody wanted to blame everybody else
in new england and i think you know cam
newton kind of brought that to the
forefront too
so you're saying in very subtle fashion
that maybe the perception of a lack of
weapons had something to do with the
quarterback not necessarily the weapon i
think it was a little overdone i i
understand people questioning the
weapons and going hey i mean he doesn't
have a lot of help and all of that but i
think it was overblown because no one
could figure out
why new england's offense wasn't working
good
and no one's gonna blame 12 on new
england so everybody just tried to find
an excuse of o-line's not protecting
good receivers aren't good enough and i
get it we see that with all the old
legends i mean at the end of eli
manning's time here with the new york
giants here was the phrase from all the
giants fans if you put great receivers
in a great offensive line around him he
could still be good oh no crap so could
i go let me play then give me great
receivers in a great all line i'll come
back out and play so yeah that's where
it was frustrating to me as a football
guy going we're not
realistically evaluating this people are
making up excuses and not that these
guys are great yet but you see new
england's got a good system cam newton's
aggressive
and they're coming along this group and
edelman's the only really proven guy
there
give him great offensive line great
running game great receivers great
defense great special teams great
coaching you could win with that guy
right yeah that's that's where it gets
to sometimes and you're just like what
okay well i think a lot of people could
win with that guy
all right the saints have dropped five
spa or three spots rather from five
and you said it last week when they beat
the buccaneers you said there's reason
to be concerned about the saints and
those concerns came to fruition on
monday night against the raiders what
can you do now to to push the buttons
and to get more out of this offense we
don't know what michael thomas's status
is going to be they could put him on
three-week ir they didn't that at least
leaves the door open for him to come
back on sunday night against the packers
but there's a potential statement game
in the offing on sunday night when green
bay goes to new orleans kind of and if
everything we've seen
so far this year in their different
context the packers shredding the
vikings in a place that ordinarily is a
great home field advantage but without
fans it's not and then shredding the
lions after spotting them a lead and we
see the saints who they didn't have
their way with the buccaneers they got
the win but was that more about the
buccaneers or the saints we don't know
and then the saints looking sluggish
against the raiders you put those two
halves together right
and
i'm not picking the saints on sunday
night let me go ahead and give you a
preview of our mega pix podcast coming
tomorrow i won't be picking the saints
what if it ends up being a blowout how
do you avoid that at this point if
you're sean payton in the saints yeah
it's a little scary i don't expect them
to be blown out just because i still
think they're you know a good football
team but how good i think that question
is still up in the air i mean you
mentioned it week one was not pretty the
offense was ugly in week one
and i don't know if they win the game if
brady doesn't throw the two
interceptions one of them being pissed
pick six and the other one i don't know
gave new orleans the ball what at the
35-yard line going in i'm not sure they
can win it with the way they're playing
right now so yeah they're one and one
but it's an uh you know an unimpressive
one in one and
you know the way the raiders moved the
ball on their defense i think concerned
me too i mean uh not the raiders the way
the lack of the fact that the saints
couldn't move the ball on the raiders
defense concerned me i mean the raiders
defense i don't expect that to be
anything special this year there's
nothing there to hang your hat on
and you know to go through that second
and third and early fourth quarter
without being able to move the ball at
all
uh yeah i think there's there's
definitely like some concern there can
breeze push the ball down the field can
they get explosive plays their defense
who's
who's the playmaker who can make a play
who can do something there you know it's
all been very underwhelming and uh yeah
i just don't know what to expect is this
the typical slow start you think from
the saints or are we seeing a team that
just maybe just passed its prime and is
kind of hanging on here and it's gonna
be like this all year i think that could
go either way
well and the talk of drew brees being
done and the saints being done we'll see
what kind of motivation that supplies in
the saints going forward i had a flash
there had a thought yeah during your
playing career was there ever a week of
preparation where
and i'm not saying the saints should be
feeling this way but it could go off the
rails for them based upon what we've
seen so far from green bay was there
ever a week that you spent preparing for
a game knowing deep down you were gonna
get your ass kicked and just blown off
the field uh
not that you
you knew that you were gonna get your
you know your ass kicked to to use your
phrase but
certainly games where i went into it
going ooh i mean
one mistake and we're gonna be in
trouble in this one definitely i mean i
can remember the 2006 baltimore opening
game of the year preparing for them with
ed reed and ray lewis just going wow
they're better than us there's no doubt
about it and uh they might just
steamroll us and kill me on the way uh
the way to the quarterback every play
but one mistake and we're gonna be in
trouble and and we made three mistakes i
know i threw three interceptions that
day but yeah there's certainly those
moments where you know the room for era
is very little
is it irony that you survived the ravens
but then almost didn't survive the
panthers i guess i don't know i know
right you know you see either way they
were both big bad and brutal they had
more
big dudes on their teams than anybody in
football at that time so that was not
the two teams you wanted to play two out
of your first three games
speaking of your buccaneers they're one
and one they stayed put at number nine
no rise no fall we're still kind of
monitoring what this team is going to be
which way they're going to break
how do you feel about their chances of
making it all click they go to denver a
place where tom brady has had some bad
experiences but he's never faced jeff
driscoll as the starting quarterback so
that gives him a little bit of a bump
but they've got the broncos home game
against the chargers and then they go to
soldier field to take on the bears do
you think brady
and the buccaneers are trending up or
are you concerned no i think trending up
and and i'm gonna watch that film right
after this show today i haven't got it
gotten to that you know but my my my big
thing with first off i mean very
fortunate you know to have carolina week
two and now you get to go play denver
without they're arguably their three
best players on the team i mean von
miller drew lock courtlin sutton i don't
think anybody would argue those three
best guys on the team they don't have to
play them that's a great gift for them
so there's still a work in progress that
would be i didn't sit there again
watching the game on tv on sunday going
oh buck's got it figured out here we go
i mean that game was teetering on whoa
the buccaneers offense is really stalled
out and carolina's going to come back
and tie this football game so yeah there
is still questions there definitely i
did think we saw more of the brady
offense early in the game more than new
england short passes get brady involved
get him comfortable with what he's
seeing and that and maybe that'll be
more of their approach going forward
um just to go all right we'll do brady
and we'll slowly infuse the aryan stuff
as we go along to maybe get this perfect
mesh at some point
but i'm not sold either like okay you
have them at nine
i probably would have put the rams at 12
or the steelers at 10 in front of the
buccaneers right now just because i'm
not quite sure what they are but but i i
get it
and to tie segment one to segment two
there's a chance we're going to have a
rematch of the 2017 afc championship
game if jeff driscoll goes down and
blake bortles is ready it could be
bortles that's right brady all over
again a game that bortles but for a
horrible call that took away a touchdown
and put the jaguars up 17 in the fourth
quarter bortles may have won you'd still
feel like he wasn't put on earth to
throw a football but he would be able to
say that he beat tom brady in a
championship game no doubt all right
let's look at the back half of the
power rankings 17 through 32
and there are the eagles i dropped them
down four spots after they lost at home
in convincing fashion to the la rams
what would you be doing to get carson
wentz back on the right track after what
we've seen so far from him this year
after we saw so much promise last year
when he was making it happen with a
bunch of no names around him well
offense is just so hard in philadelphia
i mean watching that film yesterday
it's just
there's no run game to be consistent of
it's not like carson wentz now he was he
off a little like yes did he throw did
he throw two interceptions in the game
you know one of which one was only in
the competitive part of the game the
other one was they're down by 17 and he
had a force and it forced the issue
but
you know the big thing is yeah okay
carson wentz certainly can be a little
loose with the football throws it all
arms
every now and then to lose control of
the ball doesn't know when to like die
and just go hey i'm going to get sacked
i'm going to go down you know there is
that little reckless part of his game
that he certainly can fix
but you know the eagles it's a little
bit like last year still they got to use
more to help him i mean pass protection
not great
i'm not sitting there watching the film
going oh there's people open everywhere
and carson wentz is missing them in fact
i sit there and go how many times can
they ask this guy to jam a ball into
tight coverage nine and ten yards down
the field i mean it's it's constant it's
it's earth's smashed in between two
people it's goddard smashed in between
two people so
uh there there's not a lot of support
system around a wence right now either i
know it's not perfect but i think it's
an offensive totality thing not just a
once thing
yeah and it just look this is the eagles
way they they take a while to get
rolling then they find it at some point
once we've written them off they need to
find a way to get it rolling from the
start of the season yeah the browns at
number 24. i
picked them up out of the basement i was
so dismayed by just the overall
dysfunction last week that i dropped
them to the bottom now they're at number
24 they've redeemed themselves by
beating the bengals
what do you take away from what they did
last week to give them any semblance of
hope that they can start stringing some
wins together moving forward well the
baker that offense it showed you that
they can make plays baker looked good he
didn't lose control of the football just
about the whole night i mean made really
good decisions
and then the run game as we talked about
leading up to that game
you know we saw in week one we've seen
last year
chubb is one of the three best running
backs in football he is a beast
and they can run block so those are
things to build on i mean definitely
yeah i think you have the browns a
little too low for my liking uh if i was
gonna argue with you there but they're
certainly not a finished product i mean
their defense
that's disappointing from what we've
seen so far you got these two-headed
monster at running back the receivers
look good we know the tight ends baker
corrected the defense through two weeks
though joe burrow and then moving the
ball up and down the field of them and
of course week one uh they're too
talented to be just getting gashed like
that
they've got a rematch coming up week
seven against the bengals before that
there are four games that i think will
tell us a lot about the browns
washington at dallas the colts and at
the steelers if the browns go two and
two over the next four weeks yeah
they're in good position to be
competitive i think they need to win at
least one and their best chance is going
to be this sunday against the washington
football team with a couple of extra
days to get ready we're gonna learn a
lot about washington this weekend too
because they look good against the
eagles not so good against the cardinals
it's one of the more intriguing games
this weekend between washington and
cleveland but the browns could be moving
in the right direction and they will
keep moving up if they can keep winning
the jaguars at 28 i probably should put
them higher they they beat the cults and
that win you got the jaguars at 25 just
so you know 25. okay well better than 28
they were 28 last week they're now 25
thank you for correcting me the colts
win looks better now that the colts
dismantled the vikings they went
toe-to-toe with the titans i feel like i
should have them higher than 25 but it
was just hard to find how much higher
you could go with them they can go
higher though
um and this is their chance thursday
night their annual if they even qualify
for that prime time game gardner minshew
versus ryan fitzpatrick as the jaguars
and the dolphins get together but this
is the chance for the jaguars to show
that that the colts win wasn't a fluke
because if you're good enough to beat
the cults you're good enough to beat the
dolphins and they need to take care of
business against the dolphins and uh you
know if they go if they go to two and
one
uh you know i i don't know did we start
taking them seriously i think we should
take them seriously where they are right
now that's why i feel bad that i have
them at 25. yeah they should be hot well
it was it was one of the ones that
jumped out to me i just thought wow i
mean you're giving to me i thought okay
like floria's giving the falcons too
much respect with their their crappy
looking 0-2 loss you know washington
yeah i'm not so sure i probably would
have put jacksonville in front of
washington too um you know jacksonville
i think confirmed that they're better
than what we thought even though they
were outplayed week one by the colts the
way they played last week
you know against the titans and that
game coming down to the end yeah i mean
i gotta give them a little credit right
now i do i mean the the fact that they
ran the ball like that on the tennessee
titans minchu made his plays in the pass
game you know they were down the defense
made some big stops to let them back in
the game you know those were encouraging
things they're a young team they're not
perfect but
um
yeah like right now i'm more hopeful for
them than teams like the falcons and
even washington
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports